a philosopher says humans should kill
themselves maybe an 11-year old drag kid
makes a trip to a bar and Democrats
focused once again on Russian
interference but there's a twist
I'll explain this is the Ben Shapiro
show
well a lot happening we'll get into all
of it first I want to make a big
announcement tonight 7:00 p.m. Eastern 4
p.m. Pacific tune in to the story with
Martha McCallum on Fox where I will be
revealing the title and cover of my
latest book I know I've been talking
incessantly about it for months but now
you're finally gonna get to find out
what it is will it be a book that shreds
wrecks or possibly slams does it destroy
does it annihilate who knows you'll find
out this evening I'm Martha McCallum
show on Fox News 4 p.m. Pacific 7 p.m.
Eastern tune in and find out also before
we jump into the news let me remind you
that if you wish to look stylish it is
not enough for you to go to your local
department store and then just grab a
suit off the rack it's holiday time it's
time for you to look as good as possible
and that means endo Chino they make
made-to-measure suits and these
made-to-measure suits fit better
compared to generic off-the-rack suits
not only that you actually get to
customize these suits you get to go to
the actual endo Chino store I went to
one in Santa Monica and you meet with
tailors and they show you a bunch of
fabrics and they show you a bunch of
customizations the buttons the lapels
the monograms all this sort of stuff and
then they tailor a suit made direct for
you and if you don't have the time or
you don't have a location to go to one
of these areas then instead you can just
do this online you take the measurements
yourself you choose your fabric you
shoes your design customizations you
submit your measurements with your
choices and then you relax well your
suit gets professionally tailored and
mailed to you in just a couple of weeks
all of this happens at endo Chino calm
and any premium endo Chino suit is just
359 bucks and Indo Chino calm when you
enter promo code
Shapiro's at checkout that is 50% off
the regular price for a made to measure
premium suit plus shipping is free
that's endo Chino comm promo code
Shapiro for any premium suit for just
three hundred and fifty nine dollars and
free shipping
it's an incredible deal for a premium
made-to-measure suit coat check it out
right now Indo Chino kaam promo code
Shapiro for any premium suit just 359
bucks and free shipping and these suits
was better than anything you're going to
get off the rack okay well I want to
start today with a piece a couple of
pieces of breaking news piece of
breaking news
number one is that President Trump now
says that he is not going to in fact to
go through with a government shutdown
over the border wall this according to
spokesman folks woman Sarah Sanders she
said this early on Tuesday the White
House according to the Washington Post
wants to avoid a partial government
shutdown and has found other ways to get
the border wall President Trump his
demands in
the Sanders standardises comments came
four days before large portions of the
federal government will begin a shutting
down unless Congress and Trump reach a
funding deal Trump has been demanding
five billion dollars from Congress for
his border wall which Democrats refused
to give but Sanders told Fox News
Channel we have other ways we can get to
that five billion she said at the end of
the day we don't want to shut down the
government we want to shut down the
border Sanders said the White House was
exploring other funding sources and
believes it could be legally done she
says there are certainly a number of
different funding sources we've
identified we can use that we can couple
with money that would be given through
congressional appropriations and that
would help us get to that five billion
dollars the president needs in order to
protect our border okay well if that's
the case why hasn't he done it so far I
mean really if that if that easy he's
been in office for nearly two years at
this point why it doesn't he just fund
the border wall this was his number one
promise to all of his constituents it
was his promise to the American people
is that border wall was going to get
done and he originally promised Mexico
was gonna pay for it Mexico's not gonna
pay for it but at least was gonna get
done right well it hasn't been done
we've replaced some of the border
fencing with better border wall but
that's about it
so if President Trump believes he
doesn't need a new congressional
appropriation then what exactly has been
he been waiting for over the past couple
of years and if he does believe that he
needs that congressional appropriation
then why in the hell is he caving to a
Democratic Congress maybe he wants to do
this again when there's a Democrat
Senate right I guess we'll wait till
2021 I mean when exactly does he want to
have this fight there are people who
were big Trump boosters people like Ann
Coulter who are livid over all of this
because she says listen he made one
promise and that was this this key
promise and now he won't even go up
against Nancy Pelosi in the house in
order to get it done or Chuck Schumer in
the Senate nor to get it done or fellow
Republicans in order to get it done he's
not willing to bear a little bit of pain
in order to prevent the vast number of
people who are trying to cross that
border illegally
and it's especially dumb if you're gonna
signal like this it just proves that you
don't have any you don't have any bite
to back your bark and the fact is the
President of the United States like two
days ago
went on national television with Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer he says I'll
only shut down I'll do a shout down
happy to do a shutdown and Schumer said
no and Pelosi said no and then terms
like Alec has s won't do that how
exactly is that the mark of a great
negotiator how's that the mark of a man
taking a strong position and then
sticking with it there really if you are
a border
how can you be okay with this I don't
really understand now maybe you say that
the border wall wasn't that important to
begin with okay that's a position maybe
you say that what we really need to be
doing is focusing on deportations as
opposed to physical barriers okay fine
you want to make that case make that
case but that's not the case president
Trump has been making so the wall either
gets built or this one's on him because
now he's not only claimed that he's not
going to shut down the government so
he's not gonna fight that way now he
claims he can do it himself according to
the Washington Post Sanders his comments
come after a series of miscalculations
by Republicans in recent days over how
to try and get Democrats to sign on to
five billion dollars to pay for the
construction of a wall along the Mexico
border of course last week President
Trump said he'd be proud to shut down
the government over the issue and then
on Monday evening Senate Republicans
said they were anticipating a formal
proposal from the White House but that
never materialized the White House never
promised a five pm proposal Senate
Republicans signaled they plan to move
ahead on an overhaul of the criminal
justice system this week so let's get
this straight
President Trump came into office
pledging to be a law-and-order president
who's going to shut down the border he's
not going to shut down the border and
he's gonna pass criminal justice reform
now I've talked on the program about I
think the cost and benefits of criminal
justice reform overall I would vote
against it and I have very strong
personal friends who are in favor of
criminal justice reform I've you know
closed political connections who are
very much in favor of criminal justice
reform both in the White House and in
the Senate as well I'm not in favor of
criminal justice reform that simply
grants greater power for wardens to let
people who they deem nonviolent out of
jail the chances that people are going
to go back to crime after they've been
in jail particularly a federal crime
very high recidivism rates are
incredibly high if you want to lower the
sentences then go through a legislative
process of lowering the sentences but if
the idea is that we're just going to do
this through a discretionary process
that ain't gonna solve the problem if
you want to get rid of mandatory
minimums if you want to rewrite the
penalties for particular crimes do that
but what this bill really does is it
says that wardens can adjudicate on
basically a case-by-case basis whether
somebody is deems nonviolence and then
if they are deemed nonviolent then they
can be released early or they over they
can have time that they've already spent
in prison count toward the time they
have yet to serve so we're doing that
you know Ben Sasse of of Nebraska has
has come out against the bill
they're a bunch of other more kind of
conservative Congress people who have
come out against the bill
a lot of libertarians Rand Paul's in
favor of the bill Mike Lee's in favor of
the bill they're there there's a lot of
controversy over this bill but suffice
it to say that this was not what
President Trump promised right what
president prompt Trump promised was that
border is going to have a wall on it
that border is going to be secure and as
it turns out statistically speaking the
Trump administration has deported fewer
people than the Obama administration did
during the same period in the first
couple of years of their administration
so for all the talk about border
security being ramped up dramatically
I'm not seeing a lot of evidence of it
and I think that president Trump's
constituents have a right to question
him about all of this one of the reasons
apparently the president Trump is afraid
of the government shutdown is because
the stock market has been dropping
precipitously in recent weeks it is now
at a loss on the ear over the course of
the entire year
Trump has attacked the Federal Reserve
but apparently it's rattled him that the
stock market has dropped which it should
if the stock market drops too much and
if the economy downturns not only is he
not going to win reelection he's gonna
get skunked and the president is not
personally particularly popular but he
does have a good economy and people can
at least point to his track record of a
success if the economy takes a downturn
he's got a real problem so in other
words the stock market which has taken a
dump for a variety of reasons including
the fact that President Trump has
decided the tariffs are a good way of
making trade policy the stock market
takes a hit and then President Trump
decides that border security is less
important than criminal justice reform
again I got a question the priorities I
do just politically speaking I have to
question the priorities here they don't
make a lot of sense to me meanwhile in
other news for the Trump administration
Michael Flynn president Trump's former
national security adviser is about to be
sentenced today or he has been sentenced
today rather a judge began the
sentencing for president Trump's former
national security adviser saying he
needed to address other issues before
deciding the punishment that Flynn
should face both prosecutors and defense
attorneys had urged that Flynn faced no
prison time for his crime noting he was
an early cooperator in special counsel
Robert Muller's investigation of Russian
interference in the 2016 election we
still don't know what Flynn exactly has
said here but in their sentencing
submission Flynn's attorney suggested
that he might have been fooled into
lying to the FBI because he'd not been
warned in advance that doing so is a
crime that prompted the judge to request
more documents the special counsels
office last week pushed back on the idea
Flynn was mistreated as I discussed last
week on the program I am not under the
opinion that Flynn was while
was treated in a way that other people
are not mistreated by the criminal
justice system
very often police call you in for some
sort of interview you are not in custody
and then you're not given a lawyer
prosecutor said the court should reject
the defendants attempts to minimize the
seriousness of these false statements to
the FBI nothing about the way the
interview was arranged or conducted
caused the defendants to make false
statements to the FBI a concession from
Flynn could disappoint supporters who
for months have advanced the notion that
Flynn was wrong - although reluctance to
admit guilt could prompt the judge to
send Flynn to prison the real issue here
is that Flynn's
bad activity really has very little to
do with Russia for all the talk about
him having you know connections with
Russia really very little of this has to
do with Russia at all the vast majority
of his bad activity has to do with his
relationship with the Turkish government
was basically paying him as a lobbyist
without him registering as a lobbyist I
don't think that the Flynn plea is going
to result in anything truly nasty for
president Trump what's ironic about all
of this is that the left has spent just
an insane inordinate amount of time
talking about Russia interference in the
election talking about all of trumps top
officials being ensnared in Russia
interference when it turns out that all
along the best legal avenues they had
for attack on President Trump were the
ones that you would have thought you
would have had in 2016 right before I
knew the rush of stuff came up his sort
of personal foible with women
his financial foibles the fact that he
runs kind of a sleazy real-estate Empire
right the fact that he has always been
kind of a charlatan when it comes to his
business relationships I mean the guy
somehow made a casino go bankrupt in
Atlantic City I mean this is there
there's always been a lot of questions
about corrupt practices but the Russia
stuff took forefront because it
explained a couple of things for
Democrats it demonstrates how for
Democrats the truth really was secondary
to the priority the priority of heard of
Democrats in all of this was to deal
with jibt ax my's the election it was
not about getting to what crimes Trump
may or may not have committed that was
never the priority only that they're
only now talking about that stuff is a
secondary primarily they were worried
about why did Trump win the election and
so the Russia a narrative allowed them
to say two things one Trump was a
criminal - he stole the election all of
the other criminal activity that is now
being laid at the feet of President
Trump all that other active
doesn't explain why Hillary Clinton lost
the election it doesn't because as we
all know if Trump had simply come out a
week before the election say yeah she
stormy Daniels years ago no one would
have cared nobody would have cared if
you'd said I pay hush money to women we
all assume that he did and that's why
Democrats weren't focused in on the
Michael Cohen stuff it's why they
haven't been focused in on the trunk
foundation because their priority was
always dhila JIT amaizing
the election of 2016 in a second I'm
going to talk about another corruption
charge now being laid at the feet of the
Trump administration and then I want to
talk about a story that's kind of
shocking about how it was the Democrats
were already laying the groundwork for
this Trump stole the election narrative
very very early on but first we need to
talk about your second Amendment rights
oh I know you love your second Amendment
rights just like I do you want to be
able to defend yourself well your time
is almost up you still have a chance to
win big today from the u.s. CCA the u.s.
CCI wants to give you a free gun right
now they're giving away a different gun
every single day this month but these
guns are going fast they want to make
sure that law-abiding citizens have
weapons to protect themselves and
protect their rights you are almost out
of time to win just text the word safe
to the number 8 7 2 2 2 and get entered
right now you could get up to 24 chances
to win a gun every day it could be 24
Kimber's 24 Glocks maybe that ar-15 that
you've had your eye on but they are
running out fast so get yours now all
you have to do is text safe sa Fe 2 8 7
2 2 2 and reveal the gun you could take
home today totally free there's not a
lot of time the gunner of the day will
always disappear at midnight and they're
almost gone
so hurry right now this is your big
chance to take home one of these guns
don't miss out tech safe do 8 7 2 2 to
get entered to win your free gun right
now the u.s. CCA has a number of
fantastic services ranging from legal
defense help in case god forbid you have
to fire a gun at somebody to all sorts
of advice and and classes all sorts of
great stuff over the US CCI go check
them out right now tech safe - 87 - 2 -
again safe - 872 - 2 for your chance to
win a gun today from the US you see a
great organization I'm proud to be
associated with them go check them out
right now by texting safe to eight seven
two two - okay meanwhile president Trump
has agreed now to shut down his
embattled personal charity amid
allegations he used it for his personal
and political benefit and gave away its
remaining money according to New York AG
Barbara Underwood she announced this on
Tuesday according to the Washington Post
Underwood said the Donald J Trump
foundation is dissolving as her office
pursues its lawsuit against the
Trump in his three eldest children are
also being sued the suit was filed in
June it alleged persistent illegal
conduct of the foundation and sought to
have it shut down why well because
Donald Trump was basically signing
personal checks according to the
allegations for personal expenditures
and then funneling it through the
charity which is pretty ugly stuff
Underwood is continuing to seek more
than 2.8 million dollars in restitution
and has asked a judge to ban the trumps
temporarily from serving on the boards
of other New York nonprofit
organizations Underwood said Tuesday her
investigation found a shocking pattern
of illegality involving the Trump
foundation including unlawful
coordination with the Trump presidential
campaign repeated in wilful self-dealing
and much more one of the allegations
with regard to the Trump foundation is
that the Trump foundation basically gave
a giant check to a veteran's group in
the middle of the election cycle and
President Trump campaigned on that basis
so this was allegedly using charitable
contributions for a political purpose is
sort of the idea the shuttering comes
after the Washington Post documents and
apparent lapses at the foundation Trump
used the charity's money to pay legal
settlements for his private business to
purchase art from one of his clubs to
make a prohibited political donation
Trump tonight he's done anything wrong
but in 2016 he said he wanted to close
the foundation but the AG blocked a move
while they investigated Underwood said
the Foundation's remaining 1.75 million
dollars that are in charity right now
would be distributed to other charities
approved by her office as well as a
state judge the Trump foundation was
never super impressive it was only about
3.2 million dollars in the bank in 2009
which is pretty small the real estate
mogul used other people's donations to
build up the Foundation's assets the
biggest donations came from Vince and
Linda McMahon in recent years The Post
reporting showed that for years Trump
appeared to treat the foundation as a
checkbook for gifts that bolstered his
interests the largest donation in the
Foundation's history at $265,000 gifts
to the Central Park Conservancy in 1989
appeared to benefit Trump's business it
paid to restore a fountain outside
Trump's Plaza Hotel the smallest a seven
dollar foundation gift to the Boy Scouts
that same year appeared to benefits from
family it matched the amount required to
enroll a boy in the scouts the year that
his son Donald Trump jr. was 11 the
Attorney General's probe turned up
evidence that Trump and Donald from jr.
Eric Ivanka Trump all listed as officers
of the charity had not actually attended
a board meeting the board hadn't met
since 1999 and
the charity's official treasurers Allen
weiselberger told investigators he
wasn't even aware that he was on the
board at one point he used the charities
money to make a $25,000 political
donations Florida Attorney General Pam
Bondi and the charity didn't tell the
IRS about it instead they listed a
donation as a gift totally unrelated to
a charity in Kansas with a similar name
during the 2016 campaign there's also
some issues with coordination between
the between the foundation and the Trump
campaign for example and there's a large
portrait that Trump bought in 2007 for
$20,000 using money from the charity we
still don't know what happened with
exactly that money or with that or with
that portrait why is all of this
relevant well it's only relevance in the
sense that for Democrats this could have
been their line of attack from the very
beginning and we'll be in a richer line
of attack from the very beginning they
could have January twentieth two
thousand 2017 they could have come out
and they could have said listen
President Trump it's got a corrupt
personal charity we know that his
business has some corruption issues and
we think that he has to in he hasn't
properly separated off from those
businesses there's corruption going on
we need to investigate all of that that
would've been a much richer line of
attack but Democrats didn't do that why
because they were focused solely and
completely on the narrative that Hillary
Clinton had lost the election because
Donald Trump cheated and they are still
pushing that nonsense they're still
pushing that nonsense the latest
evidence of this nonsense is they're
pushing a report very very hard that
suggests that Facebook and Twitter and
YouTube were all working hand in glove
basically with Russian sources in order
to manipulate data in the run-up to the
election sheriff Frankel Daisuke
Wakabayashi and Kate Conger / the New
York Times report when lawmakers asked
you to buy a unit of Google to provide
information about Russian manipulation
efforts it did not disclose how many
people watch the videos on its site that
were created by Russian trolls Facebook
did not release the comments its users
made when they viewed Russian generated
content and Twitter gave only scattered
details about Russian controlled
accounts that spread propaganda there
the tech companies foot-dragging was
described in a pair of reports the
Senate Intelligence Committee published
on Monday and what were the most
detailed accounts to date about how
Russian agents have wielded social media
against Americans in recent years excuse
me in the reports Google Twitter and
Facebook were described by researchers
is having evaded and misrepresented
themselves in the extent of Russian
activity on their sites the
these were also criticized for not
turning over a complete sets of data
about Russian manipulation in the Senate
first of all very difficult to tell what
is Russian manipulation and what is just
Russian citizens posting stuff or
American citizens posting stuff
hey this report was done with a
particular conclusion in mind the
conclusion was that the Russians were
attempting to throw the election to
trump and successfully accomplish this
the studies renewed questions according
to the New York Times about whether
social media companies have withheld
data on Russian activity and how willing
they really are to address the issue and
herein lies the actual Democratic agenda
in all of this from beginning to end the
agenda in the Russian investigation was
all about Trump was illegally elected
and to all of these social media
companies need to change their
algorithms need to change how they
provide you information need to prevent
you from gathering the information that
you want specifically in order so that a
Democrat will win in 2020 ok that's
really what's going on here let's be
frank about this to be honest about this
what Democrats want is for social media
companies to continue to manipulate the
data according to their particular
preferences under threat of government
largesse ok the under under threat of
government pressure that is what they
are looking for that is what Democrats
want and that's what all of these
articles from the New York Times and The
Washington Post are expected to do
that's what they are trying to do and
it's a bunch of nonsense if you think
that this election was twisted because
of Russian propaganda on facebook you
are out of your mind
even Nate Silver who is no right winger
is saying this is a bunch of crap if you
think that Russian means swung the 2016
election then you legitimately don't
know what you're talking about and
there's an article in The New York Times
today from Michelle Goldberg who's
really not a very good columnist and she
writes about the she writes about the
supposed link between Russian propaganda
and the election results and she talks
about the massive impact of Russian
propaganda okay for those of us who
actually know something about internet
statistics we laugh at this ok laugh at
it it's absurd absurd ok here let me
give you some of these statistics
because if you don't know these sound
big but they're not okay so according to
Michelle Goldberg Russian propaganda one
of the reports found had about 187
million engagements on Instagram
reaching at least 20 million users and
seventy six point five million
engagements on Facebook reaching 126
million people approximately 1.4 million
people the report said in gay
with tweets associated with the internet
research agency which is a Russian front
group hey now those sound like really
big numbers right 1.4 million people 1.4
million people engaging with tweets hey
now I'm going to give you how many
people have engaged engaged with my
tweets last month just my account how
many people engaged with just my tweets
last month alone not for the entire
election cycle of 2016 last month we had
197 million tweets impressions okay
according to this study the Russians got
one point four million tweet impressions
for an election cycle I had two hundred
times that amount last month yeah but
all this data is basically a bunch of
crap like they say know that that 187
million engagements on Instagram seventy
six point five million engagements on
Facebook okay my engagements on Facebook
in the last month mine personally in a
month eighty seven million so more than
the entire Russian propaganda network in
a year in a year and a half but we're
supposed to believe that's what swung
the election what absolute garbage what
Absolut's silly nonsense and yet this is
what they are focused on pushing in a
second I'm gonna explain to you why this
study says what it says and there
there's a very good reason for it
uncovered by the folks over at Media
Research Center I'll explain to you in a
second but first let's talk about how
you're gonna mail stuff this holiday
season so the holidays are really busy
and you don't have time to run to the
post office post office is great we
don't have time to schlep all the
presents over there instead what you
really should be doing is going over to
my friends at stamps comm and looking
for help stamps tums brings all the
services of newest posts postal office
right to your desk desktop buy and print
official US postage for any letter any
package any class of mail using your own
computer and printer and then the mail
carrier just picks it up no trips to the
post office required it could not be
easier print postage any day any time
stamps comm is always open stamps calm
not only saves you time it saves you
money
stamps techcom helps you print the right
amounts of postage every time so you
never overpay again and with stamps calm
you get discounts on postage you can't
even get at the post office with all the
time and money you'll save stamps.com is
the best gift you can give yourself this
holiday season I use stamps calm because
it's simply easier I don't want to wait
in line I don't want to get in the car
and want to do any of those things I
just want to be able to do everything
from my desk and be done with it right
now you
enjoy stamps.com service with a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus postage ends a digital scale
without long term commitments go to
stamps comm click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in a
promo code Shapiro that stamps comm
promo code Shapiro go check it out right
now stamps comm promo code Shapiro okay
so why exactly are all of these studies
suggesting that Russian interference
swung the election because these sources
of the study are Democrats okay this is
a study called the Oxford University
computational program propaganda project
is the study according to media Research
Center was produced by Oxford and
grafica two of the people behind that
study junk news consumption were
involved in a in another study okay that
study was all about how if you are on
the right you are a member of junk news
so basically the people behind the
Russia study we're also behind another
study that suggested that conservative
outlets were junk news which outlets
were junk news Drudge Report Breitbart
The Daily Caller free beacon life news
National Review The Federalist and red
state those were all junk news according
to the same authors who are now claiming
that Russia propaganda swung the
election maybe they have an agenda is it
possible they have an agenda yes of
course and so does the New York Times
you think the New York Times doesn't
understand internet analytics you think
the reporters at the New York Times
don't have a comparable data from how
the New York Times performs on Facebook
said they know what the actual impact of
these various various Russian Facebook
pages was and now they're trying to
claim that these Russian Facebook pages
because some of them were front groups
that were supposed to appeal to to black
lives matter folks that had somehow
suppressed black voting in 2016 absolute
hogwash Nate Silver points that out
today he says this is just nonsense of
course it didn't suppress black voting
in 2016
black voting in 2016 was the highest in
any election ever except for 2012 in
2008 both of which had Barack Obama on
the ballot but again all the Democrats
care about is the narrative if they
cared about corruption they'd care about
corruption but they clearly don't what
they actually care about is just the
narrative and the narrative says that
Trump was somehow corrupt Lee sees the
election okay meanwhile we spend a
little bit of time on this editorial
yesterday and I felt like I didn't give
it the attention it deserved you know
it's very rare on this program that I
think to myself the next day you know I
didn't do a sufficient job the previous
day usually I think to myself
yesterday's show
was just spectacular and today's is even
better but yesterday I felt like I
didn't give the full flavor of an
editorial that appeared in The New York
Times about human extinction titled
would human extinction be a tragedy the
reason I didn't give it full shrift is
because it actually speaks to some
deeper deeper philosophical points that
I think are important and I said at the
top of the show that tonight on martha
maccallum show we're announcing the
title of my book and the cover of my
book and this editorial is about as good
a case for buying my book as you could
possibly imagine my book is all about
purpose and meaning and why human life
matters and why humans are are unique
and why human human life is sacred and
all the big issues this editorial in the
in The New York Times it says basically
we should all kill ourselves is truly
the last gasp of a civilization that has
failed to recognize certain eternal
truths so this article is written by a
Clemson philosophy professor who I'm
sure is teaching wonderful stuff named
Todd Mae and he begins by saying that he
acknowledged he acknowledges that the
experience of humans coming to an end
would be a bad thing or at least it
would cause some pain because people
dying is painful he's agnostic on the
question of whether human beings as a
species deserve to die out he says and
what he's really wondering is whether it
would be a tragedy if the planet no
longer contained human beings his
conclusion it would be a tragedy and it
might be a good thing to which my
response is okay dude like they're a
bunch of bridge overpasses and near
Clemson you can just you know go there
anytime May's reasoning though is really
interesting so he argues that human
extinction would be tragic because we
have a tragic flaw which is that we have
wrecked the earth and that would be
rectified by our extinction he says
Humanity is the source of devastation in
the lives of conscious animals on a
scale that is difficult to comprehend so
will means animals so we should die
while he recognizes that nature is
itself hardly a Valhalla of peace and
harmony
he says humans are uniquely cruel and
destructive which is a weird case to
make like we are uniquely productive and
we are also uniquely destructive in the
sense that we have greater capacity than
animals but we don't for example have a
generalized habit of cannibalizing our
mates as many as x2 we don't generally
kill our stepchildren as many primates
do but according to Todd maybe we are
wrecking the world he says to make that
case let me start with a claim I think
we'll be at once depressing and upon
reflection uncontroversial human beings
are destroying large parts of the
inhabitable earth and causing
unimaginable suffering to many of the
animals that inhabit it okay I do think
that's arguable by the way the fact is
that there are more trees now in the
United States than there were before
settlers actually settled the United
States he says this is happening through
at least three Maine's first human
contribution to climate change is
devastating ecosystems as the recent
article on Yellowstone Park and in times
exemplifies so global warming so we
should all die because of global warming
and huh
second increasing human population is
encroaching on ecosystems that would
otherwise be intact so coral reefs are
going at a business third factory
farming fosters the creation of millions
upon millions of animals for whom it
offers nothing but suffering and misery
before slaughtering them in often
barbaric ways there's no reason to think
that those practices are going to
diminish anytime soon quite the opposite
well actually I do think that factory
farming is probably gonna diminish
sometime in the near future as developed
countries begin to look again at whether
they think that that's a good idea or a
bad idea but he says Humanity is the
source of devastation of the lives of
conscious animals on a scale difficult
to comprehend he says if this were there
if this were all there works of the
story there would be no tragedy because
the elimination of the human species
would be a good thing
full stop now what's funny is that he
would never make this claim about any
other species on the planet so - lots of
species on the planet that ends up
devastating the ecosystems in which they
in which they grow in which they have it
will he beat for the complete extinction
of those animal species I mean there are
places where where the deer population
is too large and it's a threat to other
populations in the area is he in favor
of not just calling the deer population
but like wiping it out completely it's
kind of a weird argument so it's weird
because May doesn't treat up people as
members of the animal community but he
does treat us as members of the animal
community so we are not members of the
animal community because we are capable
of making conscious decisions and
rational decisions but then he places
our interests on a level with animals so
my answer to factory farming as bad is I
would like to see more humane conditions
for animals but also people are more
important than animals and we can eat
animals because we need the protein and
his position is humans and animals
aren't precisely the same moral plane
but it's bad of humans eat animals why
is it bad when the lion eats a zebra may
continues by stating that human beings
bring so what
so what's his case that we should
survive maybe his case is that human
beings bring an advanced level of reason
that can experience wonder as well as
our creation of literature music and
painting well this right here is
philosophically incoherent because if a
mass-murderer wrote symphonies for
example he'd still be worth killing
presumably so if we are wrecking the
planet why does it matter that humans
aren't responsible for Beethoven's ninth
he says it would be a loss to the world
if those practices and experiences cease
to exist ignoring the fact that there
wouldn't be any humans around to enjoy
them so it would be a loss to whom a
loss to the world the world is a planet
it's a big rock floating through space I
don't think the rocks care if
Beethoven's ninth exists or not in the
end there's no real way to justify
humanity's murderous existence as long
as you say that humans and animals are
equivalent and that is precisely the
conclusion at which may arrives in the
end I'm gonna give you his conclusion in
just a second because it really is
astonishing and speaks to the nihilism
that undergirds of philosophy that says
that human beings are not made in God's
image that human beings are not special
and that human beings do not have a real
meaning and purpose in the world other
than just to be animals wandering about
on a giant rock floating through space
get to his punchline in just a second
first let's talk about how you can find
a better health insurance program how
you can get insurance in a better way
and also a way that helps build the
social fabric a way that helps you look
out for your neighbor a way that
reinstitute is exactly the sort of
judeo-christian values that I'm talking
about here on the show every single day
this is called Medicare Medicare is a
Christian health care sharing program
it's been around for 25 years they now
have more than 400,000 members all
around the country and get this over the
years Medicare members have shared over
two billion dollars of each other's
medical bills so they could help share
your needs as well also you can say you
can save a lot of money with Medicare
the typical savings for a family is
about 500 bucks a month your savings
could be more or they could be less but
could be a lot of money that you could
be saving so go check them out right now
head over to Medicare comm slash Ben or
call eight four four six one Bible eight
four four sixty one Bible to find out
more there's no pressure they are super
easy to talk to I know the founders of
it it's really great go check it out
meta share com slash Ben that's meed I
share comm slash Ben or call eight four
four sixty one Bible for more
information that's eight four four sixty
one Bible again eight four four sixty
one Bible go check it out right now
there's a reason again that since its
inception members have shared more than
one point nine
medical expenses Medicare works and you
don't have to pay for things you don't
believe in because again it is a
Christian health care sharing program go
check it out metas share comm / mentor
call 844 61 bible go check it out right
now okay
also let me remind you that it's almost
time for our next episode of the
conversation so tomorrow at 5:30 p.m.
Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific I will be
taking your questions and answering them
to the best of my abilities which means
the best of anyone's abilities live on
air so make the questions good the
lovely and talented Alicia Krauss will
be hosting and making sure that the
execrable Michael Knowles has been
murdered and buried in the garden once
again subscribe to get your questions
answered by me tomorrow at 5:30 p.m.
Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific join the
conversation if you actually want to ask
questions though you have to be a
subscriber which is why you should spend
$9.99 a month and become a subscriber
what are you been doing all this time
you listen to the show every day and you
don't subscribe who are you why what
kind of person are you
I mean I know this is a hard sell but I
mean really guys get it going
also for $99 a year you get access to
the mailbag you get to you get to see
the rest of the show behind the paywall
and come January get two additional
hours of the show I mean what what what
more can I give to you my lifeblood what
more also you get when you spend ninety
nine bucks a year you get this he left
his tears hot or cold tumblr you know
the drill this sucker unbelievable
it holds any liquid I mean literally any
liquid so long it is is not actual magma
or or acid those are the only two that I
think it doesn't hold all the other
liquids it is capable of holding that
doesn't mean you pee in it it's too good
for that don't do that don't do that to
the tumblr but it is fully capable of
holding your coffee it's fully capable
of holding your water it is it is
magnificent go check it out right now
for $99 your also check us out over
iTunes SoundCloud I remind you that I
Heart Radio right now if you go to I
Heart Radio com they have these podcast
awards that are coming up next month go
vote for us in the news category because
we appreciate it and that'll be awesome
also check us out and and review us over
to iTunes that helps us our ranking we
always appreciate we're the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
so here's the conclusion to this deeply
nihilistic article in The New York Times
about whether humans should going
extinct after this guy basically says
humans are like animals and as the
animals were really bad animals he says
so then how much suffering and death of
non-human life would be we be willing to
countenance to save Shakespeare our
sciences and so forth unless we believe
there is such a profound moral gap
between the status of human and
non-human animals whatever reasonable
answer we come up with will be well
surpassed by the harm and suffering we
inflict upon animals right and this is
he's right if you believe that humans
are just animals and have the same moral
status as animals then maybe humans
should go extinct thankfully we have a
3,000 year tradition saying that humans
and animals are not in fact the same
humans are different humans have a
quality that Aquinas would call a soul
humans have the capacity to reason
humans have the capacity for beauty and
wonder all of these things make humans
unique and more important than animals
you are more important than your dog I
know you love your dog you're more
important than your dog you're more
important than your cat it's one of the
reasons you know I have two kids and
when I hear people say that they're
their animals are their four-legged
children like you stop that right now
that those are not your four-legged
children I mean did you bear that dog if
so that's weird but also that is not a
thing okay humans are not on the same
moral level as animals and if you
believe they are then Todd may is making
a strong case and listen to his
conclusion he says there's just too much
torment wreaked upon too many animals
and to certain a prospect that this is
going to continue and probably increase
it would overwhelm anything we might
place on the other side of the ledger
moreover those among us who believe
there is such a gap should perhaps
become more familiar with the richness
of lives of many of our conscious fellow
creatures our own science is revealing
that richness to us ironically giving us
a reason to eliminate it along with our
own continued existence so basically if
you study the monkeys long enough then
you'll want to kill yourself good good
pitch man and then he says one might ask
her whether given this view it would
also be a good thing for those of us who
are currently here to end our lives in
order to prevent further animal
suffering yes that was the literally
first question that appeared to me and a
man who writes a piece called would
human extinction be okay might want to
go grab himself some rope but he says
although I do not have a final answer to
this question we should recognize that
the case of future humans is very
different from the case of currently
existing humans that was I'm not gonna
kill myself that's not something I'm
gonna do but he said he says to do
currently existing humans that they
should end their lives would introduce
significant suffering among those who
have much to lose by dying in contrast
preventing future humans from existing
does not introduce such suffering since
those human beings will not exist and
therefore not have lives to sacrifice
the two situations then are not
analogous so in other words kill all the
unborn babies don't have any more babies
but you don't have to kill yourself man
I mean just go hog wild because in a
generation it's all gonna be gone anyway
and then it's gonna look like Logan's
Run I mean the capital buildings gonna
be all covered in vines and stuff so you
have fun you but you don't have any
babies just don't have it if this is the
kind of fulfilling life that you see
yourself living buying into the deep
seeded philosophy of left enjoy man it's
all you it's all you and the value
system that the left is promoting right
now is so nihilistic and so deeply
disturbing that it's almost impossible
to describe it and this is this is not
to suggest that everyone on the left
believes that stuff obviously not but if
you don't believe that human beings are
special if you don't believe we're
created in God's image if you don't
believe if we have the capacity to
reason if you don't believe that the
universe has a rational basis that we
can comprehend if you don't believe that
any of those things and yet you are
still living in a way that suggests you
believe those things maybe you ought to
examine your first rules your first
values the stuff that you actually
believe way down deep because I would
think a lot of people who consider
themselves atheists and agnostics are
still making the same assumptions that
religious people take for granted
because they are in fact religious
assumptions about life and those
religious assumptions about life extend
to the moral sphere so the idea that you
are made in God's image and that you are
more than just a body that you are more
than just a body that your autonomy
ought to be used for the sake of reason
your autonomy ought to be used for the
sake of doing good that's something
that's gone completely by the wayside
since we are apparently just a ball of
synapses and you can see that in the
generalized attitude toward what is
actual degra gate degradation and
perversion okay that what we are about
to watch is actual degradation and
perversion an 11 year old boy who's
become a very famous drag kid so he's 11
years old and his parents dress him in
drag okay that that is in and of itself
sexualized drag queens are sexualized
the idea of dressing up as a girl in
midriff-baring clothes as a young boy is
of course sexual
okay this this little boy this poor
little kid who is in fact being
victimized by his parents because
parents got to make decisions for their
children I have no tolerance for this
garbage that an 11 year old boy gets to
decide whether he wants to appear at a
strip bar at a gay bar dancing at a
strip bar at 11 years old you don't get
to do that hey if a stranger came and
took your kid and did this they would be
prosecuted if a parent does it then
apparently it's okay on December 1st an
11 year old boy dressed in drag danced
onstage in a sexual manner at a gay bar
in Brooklyn New York called $3 bill this
is according to Amanda presto Giacomo
over at Daily wire the child Desmond
Napoli's was dressed as a Gwen Stefani
look-alike full drag makeup a blonde wig
and crop top included as he bounced
around onstage to no doubts like a girl
here's a little bit of the video and
what you can see is this kid on stage
dancing this kid's 11 I mean what the
actual effort a small 11 year old boy
dressed in drag dancing in front of a
bunch of gay men and then stripping
stripping off a dress to dance some more
and the patrons begin offering him
dollar bills they've been offering this
little 11 year old kid dollar bills this
is this is pedophilic I mean there's no
other way to put it this is absolutely
pedophilic the the club apparently has
no cell phone policy one of the one of
the people who went there this is not a
rip on gay folks by the way this is a
rip on this kid's parents and the
patrons who decided that it was okay to
hit on 11 year old boys and one of these
one of the patrons who is not a sick
person said I left after seeing a child
danced on stage for money at a night
time this was on Saturday night I've
been feeling disturbed ever since this
whole thing is ridiculous and by the way
it is worth noting that the mainstream
media has propped up this kid's
publicity RuPaul
wrote a disturbing piece in The Daily
Beast talking about how much he loved a
drag kid Desmond and the Today Show
promoted this kid saying that he's
taking over social media with an
inspiring message this is a society that
has lost its moral moorings on every
conceivable level a society that has
lost its moral moorings really
disturbing stuff okay in just a second I
want to get to the I want to get to a
couple of big stories here's here's a
story with regard to Russian collusion
they
you're not hearing from the mainstream
media today but is making the rounds in
sort of conservative media and it should
be so I said earlier on the show that
Democrats are very deeply concerned with
the idea that they lost the election in
2016 because of Russian interference how
deeply concerned are they over this that
they were preemptively concerned over
this they were preemptively planning to
make a fuss over Russian interference if
Hillary were to lose according to Roland
Scarborough over at The Washington Times
today British X by Christopher Steele
who wrote the Democrat financed anti
Trump dossier said in a court case that
he was hired by a democratic law firm in
preparation for Hillary Clinton
challenging the results of the 2016
presidential election as a pretty
bombshell statement Christopher Steele
remember the steel dossier guy he is now
saying in legal filings that he was
hired by fusion GPS and Perkins Coie in
order to gather data that would lead to
a conclusion that the election was
stolen
he said the law firms perkins coie wants
it to be in a position to contest the
results based on evidence he unearthed
on the Trump campaign conspiring with
Moscow on election interference his
scenarios contained in a seal August
second declaration in a defamation
lawsuit brought by three Russian bankers
in London the trio's American attorneys
filed his answers Tuesday in a libel
lawsuit in Washington against fusion GPS
and answers to enterin interrogatories
mister those are questions asked by the
opposing lawyer mr. Steele wrote fusions
immediate client was Lawford's perkins
coie an engaged fusion to obtain
information necessary for perkins coie
LLP to provide legal advice on the
potential impact of Russian involvement
on the legal validity of the outcome of
the 2016 US presidential election based
on that advice parties such as the DNC
and h ave CC that's Hillary for America
could consider steps they would be
legally entitled to take to challenge
the validity of the outcome of that
election so in other words Democrats
were always they were already planning
in the middle of the election cycle for
how they're going to challenge the
results of the election should Hillary
loose of Hillary won they weren't gonna
talk about Russian interference and she
lost not only were they going to talk
about it they wanted to see if there was
a way they could file a legal lawsuit to
prevent the election from being legally
stamped that's pretty unbelievable stuff
especially from a party in the media
that were complaining loudly and
everyday about how terrible it was that
president from probably would not accept
the results of the election
were prepared to accept the tutu to
challenge the results of the election
based on this crappy dossier of which
not a single part has yet been
substantiated maybe there's stuff in the
sealed dossier that's legit we haven't
heard any of it and all the stuff that
we've heard has been illegitimate it's
pretty pretty incredible stuff so this
is why I say when Democrats talk about
the the institutions of the United
States falling apart when they talk
about how they're gonna fix the
institutions in to the United States
gerrymandering when they talk about how
Wisconsin Legislature is curbing the
power of the incoming governor oh my
goodness it's a violation of the law of
the land no it is them I'm in one-sided
fashion complaining about how the system
works it is to them in one-sided fashion
complaining whenever they lose and this
is this goes to a bunch of deeper issues
about what's gonna happen in the next
couple years because what you're gonna
hear from Democrats is that President
Trump cannot be allowed to be president
he must be impeached on the basis of his
Cohen campaign finance issues and that's
what you're gonna hear from them and
they're gonna say listen we want to have
an objective standard by which we can
judge presidents and if you trust a
Democrat with an objective standard when
it comes to rules like this you are
making a foolish error because what
Democrats have shown over the last four
decades that they are not trustworthy
when it comes to setting an objective
standard by which they then later are
expected to hold so they're very upset
about election about challenging the
validity of elections unless Stacey
Abrams loses in Georgia or Hillary
Clinton loses in 2016 then they are fine
with challenging the validity of
elections they're very deeply disturbed
when a president commits some crime in
office when he said borns perjury except
if it's their president which case they
don't care at all they're deeply
disturbed about gerrymandering unless
they're the ones doing the
gerrymandering they're deeply disturbed
about limiting the power of incoming
parties unless they're the ones doing it
all of which is to suggest not that
there shouldn't be any rules but that
you shouldn't fall for the Democrat
trick that suggests that they are
actually interested in engaging with you
and setting up a new set of rules
they've not established a ground a
grounded basis for us to trust them in
helping to set up of a set of rules we
can live by and until they show some
good faith in that by going after some
of their own when something bad happens
no they don't get the benefit of the
doubt in any of this sort of stuff okay
time for some things I like and then
something
that I hate so things I like today
normally I would do music but it is in
fact a Jewish fast day which means no
music for me so instead we will be doing
the best video ever so this video is
just spectacular first thought when
sunny bunch of the Washington free
beacon tweeted it out basically there is
a guy who had packages stolen from his
front porch so what he decided to do is
create a package this package was
basically a prank package so if it was
stolen the minute somebody opened it it
was going to shoot out glitter
destroying the person's car and/or house
and then it was also going to unleash a
fart smell to destroy their car and/or
house it is just amazing and this guy is
a full-on engineer so he spent like six
months doing this there's a little bit
the video it's awesome this guy took a
package from my porch and now he's about
to open it in his car but what he
doesn't know is this is a custom built
bait package that is recording him on
four different cameras and it's about to
unleash a pound of the world's finest
glitter along with some other surprises
it's so good so Amerika Amerika is
already great ok this home making
America great again America is already
great when it's filled with people who
aren't willing to spend time punishing
criminals by making over the course of
six months handmade stink bombs and
glitter bombs that have the capacity to
tape so we can all enjoy that together
that's America right there that's the
that's the spirit of the West
that's the pioneer spirit happening
right there this guy by the way is
designed technology that's currently on
Mars so I mean I guarantee you he feels
more proud of what he did with this then
designing technology that is currently
on Mars as well he should one of the
great things about humanity is that
human beings have shown that they are
willing they're they're willing to give
up affirmative goods in order to punish
evildoers
okay they're they're a bunch of social
experiments along these lines they're
really fascinating they they basically
suggest that if you are in a game where
you can take let's say that you are
given a dollar and without the other
person knowing how much money you have
you can split the dollar with that
person so you can either split it 50/50
or you can take ninety and give them ten
or you can take 95 and give them five if
it's a repeat game and people find out
that one person keeps taking all of the
money and not get and not distributing
the money equitably then people begin to
actively cheat they begin to actively
punish the person so every time so
everyone will then collude to deny that
person any money every time they sit
next to him even if they would normally
be looking for a 50/50 split it's pretty
it's pretty amazing stuff like this is
just how human beings operate and you
can see that in it's more complex
fashion with this glitter bomb and stink
bomb so good for that guy that is that
is some heroic stuff right there okay
time for a quick thing that I hate so
inter-cell by the actor who I love it
herself I think he's great but he says
that the me2 movement is only difficult
if you're a man with something to hide
okay this is just a load of garbage he
says only difficulty if you're a man
with something to hide and he earned
praise of course from Valerie Jarrett
and Shonda Rhimes for saying so what a
bunch of hooey that
a bunch of hooey that's like saying that
you have nothing to fear from the police
ransacking your house if you have
nothing to hide
maybe true maybe not you're really
depending a lot on the honesty of the
police if that is the case you are
depending a lot on the honesty of women
with regard to an objective assessment
of their me to situation if you believe
that you have nothing to lose in these
situations and then this goes back to
the whole women never lie about rape or
women never misconstrue an activity or
women never subjectively remember an
event in a way that's not objectively
verifiable it's just not true I mean if
that's actually gonna be the standard
then we should believe every accusation
about everything why is sexual assault
or sexual misbehavior any different than
any other crime why shouldn't we just
believe everybody every accusation
should immediately be believed because
people are believable you wouldn't lie
about somebody robbing your house you
wouldn't lie about somebody stealing
your car you and why about somebody
slandering you we should just believe
every accusation the accusation is in
fact the proof at that point of course
we don't operate like that because
that's incredibly dumb and indra selva i
promise you that he is taking
precautions in his own personal life so
that he does not get hit with a me-too
moment just like every other wealthy
famous person does and if you're not
you're a fool you really if you are
subjecting yourself to random women
coming up to your apartment at random
odd hours without worrying about me -
because hey I'm a gentleman you are so
stupid okay time for a couple of other
things that I hate so there's an ad that
it's the first ad that's come out from
president for president Trump it's from
Brad power scale who is the head of
president Trump's basically
technological campaign committee he was
the guy who's responsible for a lot of
the data analytics in the last campaign
here's a little bit of the ad it is not
a it's it's not the best act I think
President President trumpet achieved
more during his time in office in any
president in history and that is why I
need every Trump supporter pick up the
phone right now and deliver a personal
thank you to your president we have a
booming economy historical on
including the lowest unemployment rate
for minorities in history we're bringing
jobs back to America through new trade
deals and the world is a safer place we
need to let President Trump know that we
appreciate what he's doing for America I
need you to call the number on your
screen and deliver our president Trump
the reason that this is not a great ad
is because it assumes a level of
personal fealty to the president that is
not necessary so it is and then there's
a bunch of videos of these people saying
Thank You president Trump Thank You
president Trump Thank You president
Trump you know the beginning of the
entry says the president Trump has
accomplished a lot of stuff fine salad
but if we are really going to run just a
personal loyalty campaign I hated it
when I don't like culture personalities
and the presidency I don't like it when
it comes from the left I don't like it
when it comes from the right I am NOT a
fan of this whole you have to thank
President Trump personally for all he's
done for you I thought that was his job
right I mean that wasn't why people
elected him I thought that was sort of
his job so wouldn't it be better to just
say president Trump has fulfilled his
campaign promises and that's why he
needs your support today but this whole
you must say thank you say thank you for
to president Trump look maybe he should
say thank you to you know his voters or
maybe he should say thank you to his
donors or maybe his donors should just
say we want to see him reelected but I'm
not a fan of this particular tax okay a
final thing that I hate today
so Nicole Wallace says just very silly
things on a regular basis over at MSNBC
she's talking about President Trump and
his attitude toward the Michael Cohen
investigation and she says that
criminals are now going to use President
Trump as their model are there criminals
out there who will point to the
president and say well you know the
president's lawyer said he was warning
her oath I'm not ready who are the
criminals who are gonna model the
president's conduct while under federal
investigation and make it harder to
solve crimes yes I'm sure that's what
criminals were going to do criminals
have never been criminals until they
heard the president Trump said stuff on
Twitter then they became criminals the
the level of myopia that it takes in
order to say something like this is
really extreme but it has unfortunately
become the mainstream opinion among a
lot of quote-unquote journalists on the
left ok moving back here tomorrow to
break down all the latest news i'm ben
shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018